first let me start with congratulations
i've seen the four episodes that hbo
sent out and they're what we call kind
of good i don't want to inflate your ego
um but they're
they're rather good um and good means
great uh you know we can keep on going
like that but um can you sort of talk
about did you guys feel any pressure
with the
the success of the first two seasons did
you feel like
any pressure with season three like oh
my god like there's an audience now and
people love the show and it's critically
acclaimed and
how are we gonna you know get do
something even better or were you sort
of like in a little bubble like we're
just going to make our show
yeah it's kind of the latter you know
you just kind of
yeah i i think i learned at snl that
you know it's always like it's a roller
coaster you know and like the minute you
know one
one week they would love you and the
next week they would you know hate you
and you know if you read stuff online
about what people think and everything
and so
i kind of
stopped doing that and just go oh well
this is what i can control when you just
try to do your best on that day
you know and
i i really like this season i would
definitely say it's uh
you know we definitely tried to um
you know it's like the best stuff i
always feel like are the people who are
making it for themselves you know and
for us it was
you know within the writers room it was
just kind of saying well
what would just happen next and
you know and trying to go deeper you
know and and make sure that it's growing
that we're not doing the same things
over and over again
can you sort of talk about the balance
of
well we love steven root and we want him
to be on the show but there's an element
of you know is it more is it more
realistic on the show that he gets
killed you know like can you sort of
talk about is there like balancing the
actors that you want to work with with
making the storyline sort of follow what
should happen
yeah you
i think it's kind of like you just try
to take it step by step and then you do
kind of go
well
you know
barry tried to kill fuchs at the end of
season two
but fuchs was really savvy
you know and he escaped and it's like so
he
you know i say this a lot in the
writer's room if i say well if i'm
playing fuchs what i would say is i
would say well my character would
probably do this
you know or if i'm playing sally it's
this or if i'm playing kusano
and you know you try to approach it
hopefully
with that in mind of you know every
character has a reason to live you know
so
even when we have small parts
you know um
i kind of think well i've played those
parts before so you want to make sure
it's like
you know the actor came down there to
play it you give them something to do
you know even if it's one line you try
to give them something to do
that's
interesting and you see what they bring
to it
but um
but to really answer your question no i
mean
it you know i feel like you know uh
glenn fleischler is an amazing actor
played gorham and it just became really
apparent by the end of season one where
it's like
this won't work if goron's around for
him you know
and it's how the writing went you know
and that was that was
awful that was really tough because we
all really loved working with blind i
can only imagine what it's like to tell
as
an actor i can't imagine what it's like
to tell another actor you know um yeah
we're going to be killing you off oh
it's the worst it's the worst part of
the job
by far having to tell or
having to tell somebody you pay your
recast which we've had to do or your
part got cut
because i've established i've i've
experienced all those things
you know for the most part you know so
or i've established or have had you know
i've i won't say the movie but i mean
i've been on a red carpet of a movie and
they the producers like
did you see the movie
i go no
and they're like
you're not really in it
and it's yeah it's it stinks yeah it
stinks but
now i've been on both sides but i get it
you know when you're trying to make big
story work you know those things happen
uh i can't imagine being on a red carpet
um
i can't imagine that happening that
it's a tough one that's a tough one and
that was someone's mistake you know that
was a mistake that wasn't like them
being callous that was them going oh god
no one told him you know
i i'm sure no one wanted to yeah yeah um
so you were shooting barry up until the
end of last year and it's coming out in
a few weeks or it's coming out the end
of april um have you been sleeping
oh yeah no
not at all yeah we're posting barry
so we're you know today we've mixed
episode six so i'm going to that after
this
so we're mixing episodes right now and
then i'm also
this morning writing season four and
you know um and doing press you know
so yeah it's uh it's a lot of work um
has uh
has hbo actually said to you
uh a season four is a go or they give
you now
no that's not the way it really works
it's all kind of like hey let's see how
things go and you know
yeah yeah there's there's no f in way
that people are going to watch season
three and be like oh this show's not bad
we don't want more
you never know i mean no but we we're
we're
attempting it yeah please i i watch an
awful lot of movies and tv and i can
tell you when something is you know what
i mean man like uh
like there's no no chance hbo doesn't
want more zero percent
you know i'm glad you dug the first four
episodes it's really weird to be uh
you know they are kind of in your your
you know our little lab you know and
you're not really
oh you're just thinking about it just
like you're just alone in your room with
a little project and then
and in this case it's a project involves
hundreds and hundreds of really talented
people
and it's like kind of our own little
thing that we know about and then
suddenly
you know people aren't seeing it now and
it's yeah it's
that that's surreal
yeah the the thing that barry does so
exceptionally well and i commend you and
alec and everybody
uh who works on it is that you manage to
make something that is very funny and
also very dramatic in the st like and
the filmmaking behind it is also just so
well done like it's just it balances all
these different things and each part is
just so exceptionally well made um and i
sort of wanted to touch on that with the
writing which is when you guys are
writing the scripts how are you figuring
out the the level of the drama and the
comedy that's in each episode i mean can
you sort of take me through a little bit
of the writing process
um
i would say that
you know most of it is kind of by feel
you know you're kind of going
um
well okay you know first day of writing
season three i mean the first thing i
think i said was okay so kusuno knows
um we wrote ourselves into a corner
what happens you know and then it's just
a conversation everybody's just
throwing things out and we're talking
about it and we talk about it and then
i like i have a big i like to be wrong
fast because you're going to be wrong so
i like to be wrong as fast as possible
so i tend to immediately go up on the
whiteboard and just start writing out
possible episodes like all right in
episode one it could look like this in
episode two you look like this and it's
just
bench kind of big
tentpole moments you know what i mean
and you go this this and by the end of
the first episode this could happen
okay and then
and then you come back in and then you
kind of go oh you know what maybe
this should move here um a good example
i could talk about is uh season two
i was doing after season two and i put
up like what could be the first four
episodes and in episode four of season
two
was what if we see
uh
in um
afghanistan and you see the first time
he killed somebody
and that he was really lauded for it it
gave him a
feeling of acceptance
and then
someone in the room was like no what if
that's an episode one what if that's the
end of episode one and you go oh yeah
well that's way better and now
suddenly
all this stuff that we were kind of
kicking down the road now it's all moved
up and now this is cooking you know but
you have to kind of go through the
process of
you know making it
building a thing and then tearing it
down and building it up again and
tearing it down
and then you just basically
talk about it ad nauseam
and then by that point it's like writing
it takes is very quick because you've
talked about it so much
when you go into the writer's room for
that first day to talk about the season
have you been subconsciously or writing
at home um you know like all these ideas
or is it sort of just all in your
subconscious and you're just letting it
out on that first day
some yes um
you know i don't think it's a spoiler to
say this but i i do think like one of
the first things i said was like i don't
think i think the acting class should be
closed
which was an interesting kind of
feeling of like if the acting class is
gone like the equation of the show is
hitman goes to an acting class and
most shows it's like well that's the
equation so don't mess with that you
know
but what was happening is we had two
seasons and bowl seasons ended with a
class show
and the class and everything was just
kind of feeling a bit
like okay we've i've i don't i just
don't know what to write about these
scenes anymore we've done a lot of the
scene we're going to start repeating
ourselves
and so it's like let's just take that
out and once we took that out it became
both liberating and kind of terrifying
because you the other elements now
aren't connected they're now free
floating around in space
and so
um it became about
almost kind of writing a new show
you know in a way with the the kind of
what's driving barry now what's driving
kushner what's driving sally was driving
fugues what's driving your whole hank
all those things are much like very
different this season in terms of
the way they have been in the previous
seasons oh that that's something that um
i found also very interesting about the
season is that the
structure of the show has completely
changed yeah um which is what you're
addressing um for fans what do you want
to tease them about season three
well i mean the acting class is gone
[Laughter]
um kucino knows so it's like you know
who snow that was a big thing for us was
kind of saying like
all right what would kusuno do like he
has this information and
uh it's been six months since the end of
season two
um
sally is at like a kind of career peak
where
while barry is kind of at the lowest
point he's ever been which is really
saying something
and um
and noho hank is kind of his personal
life isn't a really great place and
he's you know scrambling at work
basically
um
but
um
i will say like the season very much for
us was kind of about and it kind of
happened organically where this idea of
forgiveness started to come up from this
idea of like
you know season one was i
i just want
you know kind of
i want to better myself you know barry
tries to get in touch with his emotions
and he does but at a bigger cost
um
and
and then season two is i can change my
nature
you know
can you change your nature
and now season three is kind of
this idea of
well those things i don't know if those
things work can i be redeemed you know
and um
he's really up against the wall this
season and and you know um
you know the the berry character this
season is the first time you really see
him kind of
latching out to people he loves and you
know it's it's uh he's very vulnerable
and cornered
you know at the beginning of season and
he's trying to
now just get these kind of basic things
of of um
feeling redeemed and forgiven by people
you know he's kind of um
you know it's
he's in a bad place but it's it's
definitely
i think what barry doesn't understand is
that there's consequences
i don't know if he gets there
[Laughter]
it's
that's that's very very true after
seeing the episodes
yeah
um he understands that there's
consequences
what is it like actually the
relationship with hbo now that you've
made two seasons they know what the show
is how much do you have to sort of lay
out to them everything you want to do
with like a season three and how much is
it sort of them being a little more
hands-offish like i'm just curious what
like what the notes are like from hbo
and how much do they want to know i mean
i i'm i feel very lucky we work with amy
gravitt over there and and she is just
amazing and it's it's amazing to be a
part of the thing where
the notes you're getting are
are very thoughtful and kind of like she
just loves solid storytelling you know
and she just wants to see something that
is
well told so you know there's episodes
this season that
especially later in the season that are
very rough you know there's not a lot of
comedy you know and she's like that's
great that feels right for the
characters you know and she very much
is in tune with the the people
you know which
has been amazing but then they'll also
let you do some crazy stuff and go
huh all right yeah go with it
you know
yeah sure that's yeah that's great
uh in an ideal world i'm sure you've
been asked this before but in an ideal
world do you have like an amount of
seasons that you want barry to go for do
you like is it like a four season plan
like a five years
yeah i don't know i mean we just kind of
take it scene by scene i mean that's
true i mean it really is just kind of
step by step you know and then i think
the big thing that i'm always thinking
is like what is truthful
you know what's what's the truth and
then what is um
you know um and and then
kind of what's the logical thing and
then you know you just try to
i think we'll find a point where we kind
of look at each other and go yeah yeah i
think this is it you know
um
so but it's definitely
yeah i mentioned to see what people
think of this season i mean i i think
it's i mean
you could say this we screened all the
episodes for the writers and one of our
writers
that one of the later episodes had a
panic attack
okay
so i took that as like a good i was like
okay
i mean they're fine but i was like oh
okay well that's i mean it was terrible
they had a panic attack but i was also
kind of like oh okay well
we'll see what let's see what people
think
um uh when you guys are writing the show
how much are you thinking about budget
when you're actually writing how much
are you thinking about like well we can
block shoot this
and you know and you know what i mean
like the actual
i guess
i'm curious about that
yeah you what you end up doing is what
you always hear is eighth of a page
scenes gonna kill you you know like a
scene where it cuts to somebody
buying a coffee real quick and then they
see a you know something on their phone
and they go what and then they run out
those are the scenes that end up
schedule wise where you know it rogers
our producer will come up and go could
this happen in the
apartment set
could be be brewing coffee at home and
see it
because we have a schedule you know and
i think that's always the big difference
between tv
and and movies you know like
i remember i went and saw
this advanced screening of the irishman
and i walked out and ava duvernay was
there and we were talking about
man the amount of coverage and the
amount of kind of eighth of a page
scenes in that movie like scorsese just
goes like no we need
yeah you shoot the scene in the coffee
shop or the guy does this when you're
out you know you know the the whole
scene of robert de niro getting into the
plane and then they cut inside the plane
and on television you would
you know what i mean it's a thing of the
amount of coverage
um
you have to kind of think about because
your schedule you're moving like this
you know
so um
sometimes yes you know sometimes you do
have to
uh
um
think about budget in those ways
but then there's other times where i
kind of like to
go okay well these scenes are pretty
small these episodes are kind of small
and we're kind of saving it for this one
big episode where there's a big set
piece you know what i mean so this big
set piece it's going to have it's going
to take us longer to shoot that episode
and it's going to be more expensive
so to balance that
you know one of the earlier episodes is
pretty contained
you know
or you know that was you know two
episodes a little bit more contained
than usual so we can have this bigger
thing
yeah that's what i was curious about
what is a typical like shooting schedule
for barry is it like an eight-day shoot
a 10-day shoot um well initially
season one it was like five days six
days and then season two
you know again around six days but then
something like ronnie lilly maybe was
seven days six or seven days
um
but
but then this season because of covid
and covet protocols we had longer longer
days i think it got to some of them were
nine days i mean there's a one episode
that's pretty
involved later in the season that it was
about i would say nine ten days
the um is there a character that ends up
being the toughest to write for
in the room or is it is it all pretty
much the same
honestly barry it's so weird that
barry's the weirdest one to write for um
it's the last one we write for i think i
i get so excited about all the other
characters
that the the thing of barry doesn't have
a story
comes up every season where we'll be
ready to shoot
and duffy boudreaux or liz sarnoff or
alec burke or someone go you know
yeah
barry doesn't really have anything to do
and so i mean season two
season two episode seven all that stuff
about barry getting in an audition and
reading for j roach and all that we came
up with that probably two weeks before
we shot it
where that episode initially was buried
we had the script we did the read
through did everything
and it wasn't until
we were kind of
i mean
i think
yeah maybe a week away
where we've thought god this episode
barry's just kind of moping around
it was him just kind of moping around he
had no drive he didn't really want
anything all season he had nothing to do
because we were so excited that kousneau
and fukes were gonna meet
and all the stuff with sally's show and
all this stuff we just thought was way
more interesting and hank on the bus
that's that episode we're like all our
head was just a map
that
somebody
thankfully was like barry doesn't really
do anything in this episode
and that happened again on season three
where it was like
he doesn't really do anything he's just
kind of watching people
and so yeah it's a thing that we have to
remind ourselves or i have to remind
myself that he needs to at least want
something every episode
uh in the beginning of season three uh
there are some pretty emotional scenes
that you have to perform
and i believe you're also directing uh
and i'm very curious what is it like for
you when you are
doing these really emotional scenes and
also directing i mean like how are you
pulling that off
um
yeah i think i know specifically the
scene you're talking about there's a
scene where i uh
i guess you could say going to a rage
spiral
and it's a pretty awful to watch um i'm
pretty terrible to
one of the characters in the show
barry's very careful
terrible um
but um
yeah you know you just kind of
i don't know you just kind of walk
through it you have a plan you kind of
talk out the
the coverage you know and
and
yeah i mean you just do it you know and
it's and there's i don't really know
what else to say i mean yeah you just do
it and
i you know
and you try stuff and you fail you know
you try one thing and it's like oh that
wasn't really let me try something else
and
you know you just kind of do it
and uh and um
you know that specific scene when people
see it in episode two
because you know
a lot of that was uh there's a very slow
kind of dollying back of the camera in
that scene and that was
kind of
you know
setting up that there's about to be an
explosion
you know
so
you know it's things like that you're
like he's about to explode and this is
going to have consequences and
you know but that was a good example of
that scene when people see it all the
consequences after that came in reshoots
because we watched it and initially
there was consequences but we realized i
realized i wrote it poorly which was it
was kind of the same thing was happening
over and over and over again
and one of the characters wasn't being
reactive
and um i showed it to
some of the writers and they kind of all
had the same note which was
that was awful
i think someone would take action
against that you know and it was like oh
interesting and then
the conversation that happens afterwards
is kind of what happened because then
you go talk to someone else and go
you know
for not to ruin anything but it's like
if very
flipped out on somebody and someone was
like we have to report him to the cops
i asked him i was like well the cops
weren't doing what did he actually do he
just gets mad at somebody you know what
i mean and then you it just became the
actual argument became not the argument
but the points everybody was making in
the writers room just became the scene
so it was like instead of saying well
here's how you fix it
the better the more interesting thing to
me is you say here's the problem
you know you just
dramatize the problem
you know so i know it's hard to talk
about this without giving [ __ ] away but
that was the the idea and those
those scenes which was really
interesting and that's why you you know
you need a writer's room you need people
to say that's that's that doesn't really
work there there are some really
phenomenal camera moves um i i think
it's the first episode but it might be
the second episode that's going through
like i
i don't want to give away anything but
like a studio setting that's the first
episode yeah yeah and um it's
it's a
it's very impressive filmmaking how long
did something like that take to do
that was the very first shot of the very
first day of shooting
that was
gavin uh kleintop or
fantastic first ad and very much my
partner and all this stuff
he's
you know he's very very good a first ad
who's like a total film fanatic you know
and it's like oh i get it like i see
totally what you're trying to do you
know
he was like you know what a bond that
crew together is if we do this big one
on the first day for a shot you know
so it was we had a what they call a day
zero so it's the day before you start
shooting and we all got together and
walked through the scene with the actors
and
just went through the whole thing and
then the first day of shooting was
um
we did it and we got it
i think it was take 16. we were done
and
totally
you know it was like
nailed it and then we shot the rest of
the stuff we were done there and i think
we
you know broke for lunch i mean yeah it
was
i mean it was one of those days where
it's like where they're gonna be here
all day
or whatever but i saw i remember after
the first take of that big winner we
were like i think this is gonna this is
gonna work i think we're gonna get this
you know it's just tweaking stuff the
thing about that shot is that it there's
a lot of different lighting there's a
lot of different actors there's multiple
locations in the shot and the location
of the camera starts much further back
and eventually gets very close
how exactly did you set up um
we i know your dp was carl um
yeah how did you work with carl in terms
of how you wanted the shot because it's
something you directed to actually go
yeah i mean
it it's something where you kind of say
well
this has to be a one or for a reason you
know i think because of digital you see
a lot of wonders now and you kind of go
why is this a winner
um
and you know the great
one shots you know the copa shot and
goodfellas
it tells a story
you know that one is kind of the best
one because it totally tells you a story
of here's how these guys work they go in
through the back they they don't you
know
it's here's this life that laureen
broncos characters being introduced to
and so
for me it was to show kind of my own
experience the enormity
of running a show you know in the house
so
this the character comes in in this big
studio
and it is kind of like you're very small
in the frame and this thing is much
bigger than you and then as
your act ask more questions and things
like that and they're trying to move
through their
day
it's um
it just becomes incredibly it goes from
objective to very subjective
and that's what i was telling carl and
you know it was built the sets were
built
for the shot it wasn't like oh we have
all these sets and the camera go here it
was like
i figured out the shot and got with eric
schoonover a production designer and
carl and we just mapped out like okay
here's where everything goes
for the shot and he built it
specifically so that's where the camera
would go and then we had kenny davis
was our grip or dolly grip on that and
uh i felt it was good luck because he
also worked on the big one or at the
beginning of boogie nights
so i felt like we were in good company
where i was like kenny davis is here
can i ask in when you guys are writing
the episode how much are you thinking
about the way you want to film
everything in the writing process like
when does your director hat come on in
the writer's room in terms of oh that we
could do that as a oner and this needs
to be shot this way you know what i mean
yeah sometimes a lot of times it comes
later because i'm so focused on like
what the story is and kind of but um
what the characters are going through
and then a lot of the times the camera
work will inform that you know uh
there's a shot later or before actually
that shot
was a bunch of actors in a hallway that
ends in the close-up of one specific
character
and that was a way of introducing that
character these two characters dynamic
for this season
but again it was kind of like i got very
into this idea of being wide
and then slowly moving in
to a close-up are you starting a thing
where you go oh this is just a wide two
shot of people and you're objectively
we're from the point of view of just
watching them
down the hallway speaking
and then we're slowly walking towards
them to kind of hear what they're saying
and then it ends in a subjective moment
with one of the characters and
again it's all intuitive i feel like
this season i got
a little too into it
like i got as the show went on it was
like that's one of those things you know
when you do think about you know okay if
we do season four
let's chill on the objective the
subjective
dollying in shots
[Laughter]
uh talk a little bit about how you
worked with carl in terms of
like the lighting and um the framing to
reflect barry's mood um
yeah
i mean a lot of that is carl and i i was
always you know the first conversation
we had together
was i said you know i really like
dps like robbie mueller
um
where it's you know
very composed but with like natural
light
so you watch something like paris texas
or or um
you know american friend you know the
vin vendors movies or the stuff you did
with jim jarmusch and stuff like that
you know that that was always something
i was really
kind of inspired by and i just like that
look you know repo man is another one
the way los angeles looks at night and
repo man is like one of my favorite
things and so
um
so yeah it was like how do you keep it
composed how do you kind of keep it
simple
um
and and i just want to know where all
the lights coming from what's the source
you know a lot of
comedy is very over lit because they
wanted you to feel bright and fun and
we're having a good time so
everything is just it looks like a
spotlight's on it you know but
i i much prefer things that
you know you see shadow you see contour
you know it's people are being lit by
you know
a source that's
way off screen you know things like that
i'm constantly amazed uh did you see
judd's uh movie the bubble i haven't
seen it yet no well there's something in
that uh movie where uh he shines a light
on press junkets and how people
um will ask actors like the craziest
things that they have no business
answering like how would you solve like
that would be someone like yesterday at
the junket for you asking so how would
you solve like the crisis in ukraine
yeah yeah yeah like something completely
out of left field so i am curious
what is it like when as an actor uh
doing press and people asking you the
craziest [ __ ] that you have no reason to
answer it yeah i don't think as an actor
i should be answering anything about
anything other than the show that i
worked on because that's the only thing
i know anything about so when people ask
me i got a lot of questions on the
junket about
you know cancel culture and comedy and
what do you think about little smith and
chris ross
and i'm just like
i i don't what why are you asking me
like no one wants to hear from me
you know it's like
i do a show that's the only thing i
can't answer questions
you know
i can't have answers for questions i
don't know the answer to like i don't
know
i really don't know you know but
so it is this weird
it is weird when you can kind of feel
what is like oh you're not interested in
the show you're kind of needing
clicks or something you know it's like
you're wanting some
you know
it is a it is hard to answer questions
now because even a thing where you think
you're just being
kind of innocuous we like even just
going yeah no that's it's too bad
you know it's like
bill hayden thinks ukraine and russia is
just too bad
and it's like no no that's not what i
meant you know
just like so
i do clam up i think a bit more and it
just
each time i read myself in print i just
want to say less
[Laughter]
i honestly don't know
if i was on your your side i don't know
what i would do
if someone asked me something about
cancelled culture because no matter what
i said it someone would take it the
wrong way yeah yeah and you just
yeah and i'm i'm not on social media or
any of those things but
the real answer is i don't know
i just i have no idea i mean i know how
i felt you know i feel about certain
things but
it
it um
but it's you know things are pretty
pretty complicated and so yeah and you
know i'm not on social media because i
am wrong all the time
i will be at a dinner and i will go well
isn't it this and someone's like well no
it's actually kind of this i'm like oh
yeah that's right and someone else will
go well it's not it's this i go oh
that's also true
you know
and i'm like i would be apologizing
every day
because i'd be like hey that thing i
said you know what someone told me
something else no that makes sense
yeah i i think the only thing that you
could get away with is like just posting
photos on instagram with no comments you
know what i mean like that's your only
safe way yeah here's a chair yeah it's
just i i am in the editing room today
that's it that's your so you know i'm on
the editing room yeah i would yeah i
just yeah i'm just i'm not i would not
be pretty good at it
um so episode three is called ben
mendelsohn someone on twitter asked me
if there's a specific movie about ben
a specific ben mendelsohn movie they
should watch prior to watching the
episode
oh any of them i think he's such a great
actor i love ben nicholson
i have to give credit where credit's due
the ben mendelson
stuff and episode three is emma barry
the writer of that episode she she was
really
she's really funny and she loves ben
mendelsohn like we just say let's you
know
you know favorite actor
uh he's he's quite talented in front of
the camera
amazing yeah yeah um so
someone else on twitter uh mentioned
this uh barry slaughters about 25 people
in the most recent season finale are we
still are we still supposed to find him
lovable
that's kind of up to you i guess um i
mean
yeah i mean i i never found him lovable
and it's fun it's interesting how people
found him lovable um
you know i think he's a highly highly
complicated uh
guy who's kind of not that bright
and pretty violent
you trying for something he is trying
for something he's trying to understand
himself but
um
you know maybe people sometimes see
themselves in these things but when when
we're writing it it's always kind of
like
what's the interesting honest truthful
thing about the guy and you know again
going back to something like goodfellas
um
you know goodfellas i'm like i'm along
for the ride wow what a cool group of
guys and then spider gets killed or the
scene where he grabs the gun from
wearing bronco and shoves it in her face
and
you know that seems awful and you go oh
right these are violent awful people you
know so
um
yeah i kind of see barry that way
it's funny you keep on bringing up good
fellas i i mean i i think that's my
favorite film of all time i could watch
that film on loop it's just it's so it's
on another level yeah it's so funny real
quick because i was talking about this
with somebody if you had to name your
favorite movies and it was like i don't
know if i could but i could say well
here are the ones that hit me and
changed me you know and if i had to go
scorsese it would probably be taxi
driver but it was just because when i
saw it you know like you see a certain
movie first and you go what is that
their best movie
i don't know but that's you know for the
collin brothers the spartan think i saw
that in the theater when i was 13 and i
just was like whoa
that was amazing
um
but
is that their best movie i don't you
know they've made some great movies you
know i don't know um so
yeah it's always tough it's always very
personal but goodfellas was one that
came out when i was 12
and i remember
my parents running it and turned on when
the first scene happened with joe pesci
and start stabbing billy bat to the
knife my dad went okay
and so
for me then i was like
oh now i got to see this move how do i
get a hold of this movie because then it
became you know forbidden you know it
was kind of like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no we can't
watch this you know yeah it's
interesting because as i've gotten older
i have pushed away from the concept of
something being the best
uh because how do you compare art it's
all subjective and also as you know when
you if you see casablanca when you're 20
you have one opinion of it but after
you've had a real love or real loves in
your life and you watch casablanca again
it's a completely different movie yeah
it's a completely different movie yeah i
mean that's why to me it's always like
what are the ones that hit me that you
kind of went
oh that's how comedy
you know
like i mean people i get asked all the
time what's your favorite comedy and i
was like i don't know but
i mean spinal tap and my python hold
rail i saw really young and i was like
oh that's how you perform comedy
you know what i mean like you you don't
push you play it kind of subtle
and you know what i mean so i guess
those had huge effects on me are they
the best comedies i don't know i like a
lot of comedies you know so
it's a tough one
yeah i've probably seen spinal tap 50
times i mean yeah it's like to the point
now where it's like not even fun i just
i know
i know every
syllable of them
yeah i mean uh i i don't i think i've
destroyed the joke it goes to 11 like
you know decades ago yeah my favorite
thing in spinal tap lately i think about
is when they're lost backstage and the
guy says you got to take a little jog
and harry says we don't time for that
it's it's just it's bizarre how good
that movie is and it's just it doesn't
make it's just on another level you know
what i mean like which is why we've all
watched it uh a thousand times well
everyone's new yeah it had a new feeling
to it yeah
yeah also i think people forget it was
like 82 when they made it yeah the only
thing kind of before that woody allen
did to take the money and run and then
our brooks had
you know real life and those kind of
funny
mockumentaries um
but spinal taps really that's the or
zelig also was pretty interesting and
well done but spinal tap was the one
that was the funniest so you've already
mentioned that barry it takes place i'm
i'm uh i'm just about out of time with
you and um but i'm curious you have a
six-month jump from between season two
and season three how did you decide on
the six-month jump was it ever going to
be longer like how did that how did that
happen
no it just kind of it was kind of by
virtue of one of the characters getting
their own show you know so it was kind
of by that you had to kind of just go
well if that would happen let's say the
fastest that would happen where they're
writing and
shooting
we gave it six months and then
you know so it was kind of by that and
then that let us kind of go well where's
everybody else at right now you know you
have talked about how you are very
specific with your opening shot on barry
in the previous seasons like with season
two the way you know he's going i forget
he's going
out of darkness or indeed he comes out
of darkness yeah he comes out of
darkness the first time you see him yeah
so with season three i don't want to be
specific because i don't want to ruin it
for anyone but there's a specific
shot of how barry is introduced and i'm
just curious is that significant in any
way i think the thing with the very
first shot of the season is you kind of
see where his mindset is compared to
where it was in the previous seasons
you know of
uh and hopefully you know
that that will come across when you see
it just kind of well here's where he's
at as opposed to
where
where he was at
you know beginning of season two or
you know beginning season two he's
trying to do front page and just pretend
that he didn't kill kuznet's girlfriend
you know he's just trying to like be in
he's in hyper denial you know and
beginning of season three you know you
know
you know you'll see i guess
completely i think that's my last
question for you um obviously with hbo
you don't have a specific run time that
you have to hit you know it could be 25
minutes it could be 35 minutes an
episode how is it in the do you end up
with a lot of deleted scenes during the
seasons or is it
not really deleted scenes but we will
like cut like lines or little moments or
we'll cut a scene
there's one scene um later in the season
that's a pretty funny scene that
actually has a guest star in it that we
cut in half just because we thought it
was
really funny and we tried a bunch of
stuff and it just wasn't
working the way that i thought it would
in the edit and so
and then there's actually a big kind of
thing that was actually going to be
pretty expensive that i was going to do
later in the season that decided like
while we were cutting it it was like oh
this is becoming about
you know um process stuff or or kind of
you know um
weird like filmmaking rather like how do
i say this it was more about the
hardware and the effect stuff rather
than like the
emotion of the scene
and so then when once he said like okay
what's the emotion of the scene and me
and the editor
frankie um government we were like
what's the you know an allegory or other
editor you're like what's the emotion of
the scene and once we figured out what
that was
the all this stuff that we had been
planning and people were doing it all
went away
you know and so that that'll happen
where you you have to call
people go yeah stop building that
you know
i wrote it i didn't write it right i'm
so sorry you know
and so that'll that'll happen
that you're i'm sure your line producer
loves those phone calls oh yeah it's
like you know what actually i think she
does because she's like oh hey we're
spending money i'm glad we didn't spend
all the money on doing all that and then
you look at it and then go yeah you know
what it was like no cut it like don't
don't do it yet we we don't need it
you know so
yeah that that that's happened that
happened on season two as well there was
a whole
when barry was telling his story about
uh iraq and we would cut you know to
afghanistan sorry to cut to afghanistan
and he's telling a story up on stage
initially the camera would push in on
him and behind him the curtain went open
and the curtain was opened on to
afghanistan and it was going to be this
kind of motion control shot of moving
past me he threw a curtain into
afghanistan
and we worked on it we tried it and
got in the edit and jeff buchanan the
editor was just like watch this and he
just cut straight from me to afghanistan
and i was like yeah yeah that's got more
energy and that works better and he was
like
you know so you try [ __ ] and it's like
oh this will look cool and it's it's
different it's interesting and then you
go
it's really drawing attention to itself
and it's kind of actually taking away
from the emotion of what the scene is
it's so funny because i love runners um
i mean i love them but i especially love
them when they're significant to the
story and but i i i wonder if the
average person watching at home who's
not like a cinephile
really i think they feel the tension of
a oner but i don't know if they really
realize they're in a winner you know
what i mean yeah maybe i i kind of like
it if they they didn't that to me it's
just like you just want to be caught up
in like what the person's
going through you know i think of great
wonders there's that one in uh
children of men that goes through the
bus and everything i mean that's unreal
and it just feels like
you're with
clive owen going through this thing and
the whole time you're just wanting to
run the other way and it's like no no we
gotta follow him you know
and it's um just uh breathtaking you
know but
it um
though those i it's like you i forget i
i know i just cuz i like i'm
a film nerd but it's like
i get caught up in the emotion of it you
know the good fellas one i'm caught up
in the emotion of it or suspense one's
like
you know beginning of um touch of evil
or
you know those things
yeah i um children of men is another
film that if you're watching or reading
this interview and you have not seen for
the love of god bush play yeah i think
it's it's one of the most underrated
movies of all time i think it's just
absolutely brilliant i mean for a guy
who's made some of like
amazing award-winning movies the
i think you know
his my favorite two films of his is that
and ut
i can watch those
all day i get really inspired watching
those films they're really they're just
so they're so inspiring all the choices
are just
amazing
i saw children of men for the junket at
the arclight hollywood
you know rest in peace until it comes
back and i
my jaw
like i literally left the theater like
with my brain melted you know yeah yeah
it was
it was um
it's just a phenomenal film i mean it's
yeah
and it's like then it's like
you know again it has like this real
momentum to it and
suspense and everything but still is
incredibly emotional and
you know what
you know i i just think it's
unbelievable i guess i really do
i think um i could talk about children
to men for the next hour but i'll leave
it alone um uh i'm just gonna say thank
you for your time today i know you're a
very busy person
thanks for anything for you steve please
you